ضمن الحالات الطبيه النادره المسجله على
مستوى العالم والاولى في الشرق الاوسط
تمكن فريق طبي سعودي من اجراء عمليه ولاده
قيصريه ناجحه لمريضه تعيش على مضخه
الصناعيه مساعده للقلب الاطباء في مستشفى
الملك فيصل التخصصي ومركز الابحاث طمئنوا
اهل المريضه بانها اصبحت والمولوده بصحه
جيده كانت الام تعاني من ضعف شديد في عضله
القلب استدعى زراعه مضخه الصناعيه مساعده
وبعد اكتشاف الحمل احيلت الى تخصص الرياض
لتلقي الرعايه الصحيه بعدها تم تحديد موعد
مبكر للولاده القيصريه التي اجريت في
الاسبوع الثاني والثلاثين من الحمل لتنقل
بعدها الى الجناح القلب بالمستشفى لحين
توفر متبرع مناسب لزراعه قلب لها
[موسيقى]
هذه المريضه اجريت لها زراعه
مضخه صناعيه مساعده للقلب تمهيدا او الى
حين توفر متبرع مناسب لزراعه القلب هذول
المرضى
يستمروا بتلقي علاجات
ومن ضمنها الدوله المسين للدم لتجنب حدوث
تخثرات داخل المضخه اضافه الى هذا يحتاج
الى متابعه دائما للتاكد من سلامه المريض
وسلامه عمله مضخم في حاله حدوث الحمل
الاضافه للتغيرات الفيزيولوجيه اللي ممكن
صاحب الحمل واللي تحتاج الى تعديل في عمل
المضخه هناك ثلاثه امور اللي ممكن تحصل في
اثناء الحمل واللي تشكل خطوره على حياه
الام والجنين
الامر الاول هناك احتمال انه يحصل ارتفاع
في ضغط الدم
واللي ممكن يشكل خطوره على الام وممكن
اكثر على الاعمال المضخه الالتهابات الامر
الثالث ايضا يحتاج الى متابعه ايضا لتربيه
المشيمه والجدين
لانه نقص الترويه ممكن ياثر على حياه
الجنين الامر الرابع ايضا هناك محتاج الى
هناك حاجه لمتابعه ادويه السيوله لانه
اضطرابات ممكن تؤدي الى النزيف او ممكن لا
سمح الله يحصل خثرات تؤثر على العمل
المضخه وبشكل خطوره على حياه الام طيب
دكتور جهاد ما اكثر ما كان يقلقهم في
العمليه يعني خصوصا انه اذا ما قررناها مع
الولاده الطبيعيه في مجهود كبير وضخلي
الدم في الجسم بشكل كبير الولاده القيصريه
نتحدث عن بنج هل هذا كان يشكل مثلا مشكله
رئيسيه لان يتضرر القلب اللي مستعمل اصلا
بمضخه طبعا لما احنا عرفنا عن
تملا بحدوث الحمل
ادخلت المريضه الى المستشفى
وتم تقييمها من قبل فريق من عده تخصصات
واضافه الى تقييم وتعديل عمل المضخه
لتتناسب مع احتياجات
الامم من ضمن الفريق المتخصص كان في
تخصصات مختلفه من ضمنها استشاري التخدير
الاستشاريه اللي هي النساء والولاده
واستشاري القلب اضافه الى تخصصات اخرى
وعمل تقييم كامل وبعدها تم تحديد موعد
الولاده
ونوعيه ومكان الولاده
فيعني طبعا هذه الاشياء تحتاج الى رعايه
خاصه
ومتابعه مكثفه للتاكد من عدم حدوث اي خلل
او مضاعفات ممكن تشكل خطوره على حاله الام
[موسيقى]